so stone yes sir welcome back
hey hey which one almost how you got in
hand there
Hey look here man I've seen this little
item right here man they're probably
back old memories for me hands of stone
actually was reactivating this but I
remember mostly about these somebody on
my folks money and I've come to see the
small ones they said with a little
Louisville Slugger they used to give it
at opening day at Dodger Stadium it was
wood
about the same size probably about the
same probably a little smaller than this
area but what I used to like about it
most is when you walk up they can't see
them and then when you come up you pull
it out you like to hit him in the face
and unlike that it's about some money so
when you get atom you say did you buy
the meat they automatically fall and the
cold part about that they're gonna
remember that for about 3-4 months after
that it's a cold cold thing but if you
get the message so when somebody else
see that dude limping down the street
don't like how he must have Oh such as
such money so it's like it's like
sending a message to all the people that
the loan sharks are doing that that's
what's gonna happen to you if you don't
pay me my money and once we started
doing that it didn't take a whole lot of
people after three or four people who
walk around hobbling around our people
who's paying that money on time some
people was even paying in a couple of
nights earlier but one time man it was a
little cat you wanted to be you know he
wanted to be a part of our little cruel
we was doing because we had separated
ourselves from everybody else that was
hanging out and he was like no man I'm
waiting I waited me and put me on put me
on I end up I'm really but where I was
from we now know if I put that out there
but where I was from I ended up making
him my little home boy and he started
climbing my neighborhood never
but the little dude man he's probably
about 19 years old man and he just
really wants to hang out with you know
I'm saying and I'm a guy and then go let
him see see what he could do he wasn't
no big ol dude either that's why I was
tripping off something but do go he was
like man you are such such money man
will you what you supposed to be pissed
and I'm like you know I ain't saying and
I'm just looking at he and he like he
like did you got the money
and the boy was like yeah I'm gonna pay
you and he Fido and after he he my home
he had to bet he would snatch the bat
from hold on man hold up man you're not
no no you gonna pay that money and he is
zoned out so bad that when he went out
you couldn't even sending myself you
know sorry to say it's just a little kid
right now I got life man but that's what
he was doing man
any situation he was in I don't know
what was going in his head man but he is
zoned out and it was all to make
murder/death/kill with for anything and
you know I you know I put him on my turf
you know the homies loved even all that
cuz he was the idiot but you know I
really still kind of feel kind of bad
man I still write do time to time man
you know I ain't got no whole bunch but
you know probably wants everything like
three four months I'm not shooting like
30 40 bucks get you a case of super song
you know I'm saying cuz I remember him
before he turned into what he was I mean
I had a wallet and no guilt with myself
but you know that's where the world's
out there you know I haven't seen him do
some stuff on his own but I'm trying to
keep the words you know the dragnet say
names were changed to protect the
innocent
yeah man I've seen blue set this tent on
fire man what folks is in their sleep
right we are you know I think he was on
that he was like hunted out something to
do as pops - oh he was like man let me
go get a Vimeo kitty so they go and I
the cocaine coma cuz he damn dope kid
betting on a 10th family on the 10th and
don't nobody is he strike out running
down the street come back he'd come back
bamming on a 10 again don't nobody know
what he doing but he got some lighter
fluid in his hand and he's knocking on
the tick all around the tip but he
sprinkle a lighter fluid over him and he
said oh you ain't gonna wake up they
took a match you struck it booth and it
immediately
you know that's plastic it immediately
go into the flames right and it was a
dude a female in there they woke up
their teeth I think you went up and like
probably about 10 15 seconds whole tent
and globsters engulfed in flames
when they come running out the dude came
out first I don't know if you know
anything about that plastic on them
tents and they did the zippers if it's
on fire you nothing a fun night the
zipper so when he come running out BAM
with the first one he went out the
plastic stuck on him still so when he
run it out he come out the front of him
is all on fire they have to put him roll
him on the way and the little dude still
when tried to kick the money from him he
was all in his pockets and everything
and I think about some of that stuff man
and I thank God today man I'm still here
you know I'm saying that's why today I
do try and help folks you know I'm not
you know he ain't done with me yet I
still got my character for some ass but
I really think about stuff before I do
it today and I think if wonder if that
was my cousin on my uncle so that's why
a lot of stuff I don't get myself caught
up in you know I'm still Who I am you
know I'm saying you know you know I
might even you drunk out in and say cuz
a few times but for the most part minute
I look at it man I don't even see it
work for you you know I'm saying I I
think I got well I'm breaking it back a
little bit yeah 82 83 when we just
really turned up before I came out here
I think I came out here like 87 88 a lot
of my older
boys and got life Hindus is just coming
home I'm like 82 1983-84 I did my the
year I graduated was 84 so basically for
the most part of my my era I'm 53 most
most of the key because a lot of my life
in my neighborhood so like 84 to 88 them
dudes is just coming home now whole life
go the whole they whole mentality
everything is still prison and you know
I didn't did a few years in there
I didn't really do no long stretch and I
look at the way I think now and the way
they think I mean I was well on my way
to that but while it's just crazy that
they're whole this this right here is is
foreign to them really they feel more at
home in their be like em and this just
regular stuff you know I thank God every
night man and I didn't have to go back
and that's why the layout of how and I
don't think got to do a day bro so for
the most part I do keep myself straight
now you grew up in South Central
yesterday and what do you see the
problem with like that community so many
families are broke for the most part
we're gonna take it back me 53 uncle's
aunties everybody like they say it takes
a village to raise a child the drug
advocate became basically what went over
North went over there with Noriega yeah
Bush CIA any what but the crack hit when
crack my community is really hard right
our mentors and role models started off
when I was young it was players
it was fly it was a rich man high to
smoke cocaine so them you know everybody
wanted to be players balls you know as
it progressed he's in every baskets and
that [ __ ] man when I was young but for
the most part all those dudes they're
the ones that ended up getting rich are
going to jail for life became these
pushing baskets lose and then a young
kid if you're not respecting your mother
your father your uncle's your aunties
have fun raised by a grandmother who's
too old to actually really do anything
or put any real discipline down or just
on the strip because I'm a grandparent
today to my grandson really can't do too
much wrong anyway and I tell his mom I
hate that boy you know I'm saying but if
they ain't got nobody to respect nobody
to look to for no guidance on what it
should be
come on what do you think that's gonna
happen if they run around his mom's
taking the food stamps and smoking him
up with the dope man it ain't no food in
the house how was he gonna respect her
if he don't respect his mama [ __ ] you
think he gonna respect you so it all
starts back I mean the begins with drugs
and ends with drugs in the family I mean
I mean I don't know I don't know I don't
want to go too far but for the most part
I think they knew that too [ __ ] up but
I mean this is like now it's a lot
better that this generation is coming up
now like I said they said in the Bible
it's gonna be wiser but weaker they
smart as hell not to use phones and
computers at 1 in 2 years old lot of
them don't believe in God you know don't
make sense they're computer but they
it's not as much crack in the parents of
more at home now so I don't think the
next generation it's gonna be as bad as
these can see these can't they didn't
have nothing they didn't have to respect
nothing so what do you expect him to
come out and respect on the streets if
you don't have to respect your mama see
I had it respect mama if I do spec my
mother I have about 4 uncles they they
might not all come the same day but they
coming to get that ass pops this day at
the house he coming to get that ass
and my mom's gonna get that ass so I got
about seven eight weapons coming for
disrespecting my mom's these kids they
slapping their mamas and calling them
[ __ ] so if they gonna do that to the
person that raised them what do you
think he care about anything else so you
know it's good it's got to start over we
got to start all over from the fabric
man but that's my take home all right
and that's a wrap thank you so much for
talking to me and sharing your stories
thank you
you